[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire avec aujourd'hui le
photographe frédéric chaubin pour stone
age un gros livre qui vient de paraître
chez taschen sur les châteaux forts en
europe
marianne régler qui publie un instant
dans la vie de léonard de vinci et
autres histoires où elle raconte des
instants cruciaux dans ladite grands
artistes comme de starsky claudel jk
rowling picasso ou le caravage est
thomas leleu la star internationale du
tuba qui sort un nouvel album born to
move qui aurait pu penser qu'à un
tubiste eux ferait un jour un album
intitulé born to move mais commençons
tout de suite par notre époque qu'est ce
qui caractérise ce début de 21e siècle
et bien voici la réponse de thomas leleu
en images un décor effectivement
qu'elles ont et auront cette habituée
arrêts au cours de l'année oui en effet
c'est quelque chose qui m'a qui m'a un
petit peu choqué je pense un peu comme
un comme comme tout le monde et c'est
cette façon c'est ce jusqu'au boutisme
quelque part de la bureaucratie ne plus
rendre accessible la lecture dans un
dans un pays où nous parle souvent de
l'exception culturelle française
maintenant ben voilà normalement
aujourd'hui ça n'existe plus mais c'est
sûr qu'on s'en souviendra
et maintenant l'image de marianne réglé
oui donc il s'agit de du tableau
salvator mundi acheté 1000 $ et revendu
plusieurs fois jusqu'à atteindre la
somme de 450 millions de dollars
évidemment ce qui m'a frappé à propos de
ce tableau c'est le le potentiel
romanesque que recèlent les oeuvres
d'art mais aussi il symbolise aussi
quelque chose de notre époque
matérialiste me semble-t-il c'est à dire
que il ya 500 ans quand ce tableau a été
peint on attribuait au christ le pouvoir
de
d'aider les hommes a triomphé de la mort
est aujourd'hui me semble-t-il
on s'adresse plutôt à l'oeuvre d'art et
aux artistes et c'est quelqu'un a le
pouvoir de conférer une parcelle
d'immortalité c'est peut-être plus tôt
léonard de vinci et enfin l'image
choisie par frédéric chaubin c'est une
case de tintin c'est la faire tourner au
sol si je me suis je ne m'amuse
tout à fait mais c'est surtout une
invitation au voyage puisque désormais
les frontières en s'ouvrir et je pense
que cet été s'impose une visite à nyon
précisément au bord du lac léman où se
déroule une exposition de photos de
château en l'occurrence les miennes on
n'est jamais mieux servi que par soi
même donc voilà c'est une une porte
ouverte sur ce tournage en effet
d'ailleurs vous étiez venu la première
fois dans cette émission pour une
exposition de photos aujourd'hui c'est
le gros livre
eh bien on en parle tout de suite
[Musique]
sanef bas vous publiez en effet stone
age chez taschen un gros livre de plus
de 400 pages un monument à la gloire des
châteaux forts bâti en europe entre le
11e et le xvième siècle c'est alors que
justement commencé avec ses châteaux est
d'abord leur style c'est un véritable
style architectural que vous montrez
dans vos photos un style que vous dites
fondée sur le principe de défense
passive mais qui va inspirer
l'architecturé moderne en fait alors les
primitifs les plus anciens les ceux qui
sont à l'image comme celui de sada bas
par exemple sont effectivement ceux qui
sont les plus proches de ce que va
produire une certaine forme de
d'esthétique moderne voire brutaliste un
peu plus tard à partir des années 50 60
et il est difficile de ne pas concevoir
un clin d'oeil en quelque sorte de la
part de ces architectes les plus proches
à l'égard en fait de ses références
primitive alors ce que ce qui est
perceptible au travers de ces images
c'est que les volumes sont des volumes
élémentaires qui sont évidemment en
rupture avec les architectures
ultérieure mais tout à la fois en
rapport avec ce que va produire une
architecture moderne et ça s'explique
par le fait que ces productions sont des
productions en quelque sorte innocente
en fait sans intention autre que la
fonction ce sont des fonctions
évidemment défensive et cette espèce de
priorité donnée à la fonction va être
une des mantras du de l'architecturé du
20e siècle la forme suit la fonction
selon la formule de louise sullivan qui
a été adopté par les modernes less is
more vous connaissez également cet autre
formule tout ça n'a jamais été aussi
bien illustré que par cette architecture
oui effectivement effet c'est assez
impressionnant celui là c'est lequel
celui là il est très impressionnant
parce qu'on a l'impression qu'il n'a
aucune leurs prières
alors celui là en fait n'a aucune
meurtrière évidemment c'est c'est les
productions justement les plus
primitives ou en quelque sorte
les assaillants brighet devant la porte
et se contenter de cela
ensuite la poliorcétique c'est à dire
l'art du siège s'est développé et les
châteaux sont devenus proactif en
quelque sorte c'est à dire qu'ils ne se
sont plus contenter d'être une sorte de
de vase clos darche de structures
fermées mais également des éléments qui
permettait un retour offensif vers
l'adversaire et ça a été c'est devenu
évidemment indispensable à partir du 15e
siècle notamment où l' architecture ses
pardons l'artillerie en fait a vu le
jour s'est développée et est devenu à
chaque fois plus performante évidemment
en obligeant les constructeurs et les
ingénieurs à s'adapter
celui là avec sa structure annulaire on
voit là aussi à des à des esthétiques en
fait tout à fait élémentaire qui nous
parlent tout particulièrement
aujourd'hui vous parle également dans
votre livre de vigilance verticale de
vous parler d'architecturé ascensionnel
alors le réflexe premier à partir du
moment où on est dans un registre encore
une fois très élémentaire très primitif
c'est évidemment de se mettre en
surplomb pour en quelque sorte surmonter
l'adversaire l'antagoniste potentiel le
château que vous montrez là est tout à
fait tout à fait extraordinaire il donne
quand même une idée assez précise de ce
qui était le climat médiévale et l'
angoisse qui devait être prédominance et
un château très ancien qui date du 12e
siècle
c'est quasiment pas un château 7
pourrait être une un refuge de berger
mais on voit bien que le volume est
quand même très important et cette
nécessité de s'arracher du sol
évidemment encore une fois lié à la
manière la plus immédiate la plus
évidente de d'affronter l'adversité
ça leur donne d'ailleurs une dimension
presque biblique
elle s'apparente en fait à des arches
ses structures et c'est ce qui fait
d'ailleurs tout leur charme
c'est une façon de surveiller au loin
aussi ça paraît
une évidence alors c'est évidemment une
façon de surveiller au loin c'est une
façon de c'est une architecture parfois
dissipatifs comme le château de mus
homélie que vous présentez derrière vous
qui êtes un château qui comme vous le
voyez sur 1,1 des plants sains dépend en
fait de ce rocher est quasiment pas
visible il ne l'est que de l'autre et il
est de toute manière quasiment
inaccessible c'est véritablement le
château inexpugnable par par définition
par excellence
mais ce qui est frappant c'est qu'on se
dit mais des jets et c'était quand même
des constructeurs extraordinaire pour
aller monter un château dans des
conditions pareilles
il fallait trois ses amis ils n'ont il
fallait très certainement oui avoir les
moyens physiques qu'il permettait à voir
le temps qu'il permettait mais encore
une fois ce sont des structures qui sont
très élémentaire celui là par exemple le
château dhafra est d'autant plus
extraordinaire qu'il est dans un
environnement qui relativement plat
c'est quasiment un château plein celui
là mais on voit qu'en fait le réflexe
était quand même de ceux de se hisser
sur le rocher pour encore une pour
satisfaire cette cette nécessité que
qu'on est en train d'évoquer depuis
quelques minutes
est ce que l'on sait qu'il habitait
qu'il a fait construire est ce que ces
châteaux forts sont particulièrement
documenté ou est ce que ce sont des
mystères alors certains sont
parfaitement documenté comme celui que
vous montrez à l'image le château dels
qui est véritablement une icône de
l'architecturé castrale est un des indes
est un des lieux d'attraction
touristique les plus puissant
d'allemagne
d'autres en revanche reste très
mystérieux comme celui de dafra qu'on a
vus auparavant il a été restitué c'est à
dire qu'ils étaient remis en état comme
la plupart des châteaux auxquelles j'ai
été confrontée
mais je ne peux pas vous dire qui ni
quand a produit ce travail et je ne peux
pas non plus vous dire exactement qu'il
occupait c'était sans doute un château
de garnison celui là alors que le
château dels en allemagne que l'on vient
de voir était en fait un château occupé
par une famille parent c'est un fief
il y a eu 33 générations qui se sont
succédé
et ce sont ces cesser ses branches
familiales
qui ont constitué tous ces éléments qui
bourgeonnent en fait sur la façade qui
comptent qui en quelque sorte donne
cette complexité à la structure
d'ensemble le château ce mail rôle mais
également 7 tours plus qu'un château
d'ailleurs comme il y en a beaucoup en
fait au nord de l'angleterre et fassent
hurler les îles britanniques aussi bien
en irlande qu'en écosse c'est évidemment
une tour de guet et c'est pour
l'anecdote
un des lieux qui sont associés en fait
au mouvement romantique et qui a inspiré
semble-t-il walter scott qui enfant
jouer à ses pieds walter scott qui est
l'auteur scott étant l'auteur de
d'ivanhoe il va nous et bien sûr le lot
c'est lui qui a inventé le russe ivanov
et voilà et qui a surtout en quelque
sorte contribué à réinventer le moyen
âge était une période en déshérence qui
en fait émergent de nouveaux dans les
consciences à la fin du xviiie et
s'épanouit au 19ème avec la la prise en
compte de la question patrimoniale et la
volonté de redorer en fait 7
cet ensemble de vestiges de
réminiscences sur le mode du récit
national d'ailleurs le plus souvent
alors voilà un exemple assez
extraordinaire de deux structures
verticales en fin de de celui là
également au casque alenya c'est ça ce
sont des châteaux des abruzzes qui sont
quasiment en fait en porte à faux c'est
à dire qu'on a on a le sentiment qu'une
partie du château surplombe le vide ce
qui donne évidemment une dimension extra
diamant spectaculaire puisque après tout
mon travail comme un travail de
photographe
donc il s'agit quand même de produire
des images qui suscite une émotion ce
monde que vous décrivez dans ce livre
frédéric chaubin vous dites qu'ils ne
évidemment qu'il ne connaît pas encore
leurs frontières ou plus exactement que
les frontières à l'époque sont floues il
ya des fiefs
il ya il ya des pays mais est ce qu'il
n'ya pas encore d'état nation qu'est ce
que ça change un pays enfin du moins une
époque où il n'y a pas de frontières
alors ça change énormément de choses ça
justifie déjà le fait d'avoir entrepris
un travail qui recouvre tout le
continent européen puisque évidemment
les frontières actuelles ne font pas
sens et donc si on considère par exemple
et château normand c'est à dire de
manière indirecte peut-on dire les
châteaux français
eh bien on va en outre trouvé en
angleterre comme on en trouve en france
comme comme on en trouvera également au
sud de l'italie où en sicile voir au
moyen-orient et cette réalité de de
l'absence de frontières qui est lié qui
est dans le droit fil de l'effondrement
de l'empiré carolingien à l'exception du
saint-empire romain germanique qui est à
l'est va créer une sorte de dissolution
du pouvoir de d'émiettement de darchy
réalisation pour employer un terme
contemporain qui va permettre
l'apparition l'émergence de ces châteaux
qui va justifier l'émergence de de ces
châteaux qui sont des lieux comme des
balises des lieux de de sécurisation
dans un environnement qui lui est
extraordinairement diluée en fait la
question des frontières est également en
rapport avec la manière dont les modèles
vont se déplacer d'un espace
géographique à l'autre par exemple là
vous êtes en train de présenter le
château bernard von qui est un des
grands châteaux gallois ont construit
par edouard premier qui est un château
qui fonctionne sur un principe d'
intimidation puisqu'il s'agissait de
calmer les gallois séditieux skis très
intéressant c'est qu'au xiiie siècle
donc edouard 1er fait appel à un
architecte savoyard qui a la paternité
du château de chillon au bord du lac
léman et qui va produire il s'appelait
jacques de saint georges jane the sound
georges bien sûr par la suite il va être
mis à contribution par l'angleterre pour
produire un certain nombre de châteaux
absolument magnifique qui sont les voilà
les les icônes du de l'architecturé
médiévale galloise enfin anglaise au
pays de galles pardon et le le fait
qu'il n'y ait pas de frontières en fait
laisse entendre que les guerres sont des
gardes privés et aux faux c'est ce que
symbolise aussi laissé château fort
on fait la guerre aux seniors d'à côté
on ne fait pas la guerre contre les
anglais alors en fait s'il ya des
changements d'échelle c'est-à-dire qu'on
dans l'est
on peut considérer qu en fait au début
de la période qui nous intéresse
l'émiettement est telle qu effectivement
on est confronté à une espèce de guerre
de tous contre tous ensuite ce qui va se
produire c'est que les monarchies vont
asseoir leur pouvoir vont s'installer
renaître en quelque sorte et on va me
passer de manière progressive de cette
espèce de combat encore une fois que
chacun contre tous à des luttes qui
seront des luttes de de potentats majeur
voire de monarchie les unes contre les
autres
sachant que les monarchies sont
également extrêmement fluctuante le roi
de france par exemple autour du valois
est entouré de ce qu'on appelle les
fiefs où mouvant c'est à dire qu'on se
rend bien compte que c'est un système
d'alliances de renversements d'alliances
une sorte de mécanique clanique
en fait qui va durer jusqu'à ce que les
territoires se pacifie avec l'émergence
du pouvoir monarchique et à partir du
moment où les territoires seront
pacifiées et bien c'est le château
n'auront plus de raison d'être et donc
on va les transformer c'est à dire
qu'une des données majeures c'est qu'à
partir du 15e siècle les châteaux
deviennent en quelque sorte des lieux de
résidence après avoir été des lieux
essentiellement des lieux de défense et
ça donne lieu à ces transformations
comme celle qui est présente est
derrière vous
sur l'image le l'image précédente donc
c'était nogent le rotrou en l'occurrence
où vous avez comme souvent dans l'
architecture castrale telle qu'on la
perçoit des espèces d'éléments hybride
de d comment dire des compositions 10
parrot où on peut retrouver une tour du
comme celle là voilà sur la gauche en
fait un donjon primitive du 12e siècle
sur la droite à châtelet c'est à dire
l'entrée du château ou qu'ils aient tous
le térieur est d'aider des toits en
était noir et une aile gauche qui relève
de la renaissance et on voit donc que
les périodes se succèdent en
transformant en quelque sorte en
métamorphosant l'objet château en fait
on passe de la guerre à la paix on le
voit bien sûr absolument sûrs c'est un
des titres de votre sa ça se passe
à partir du 14e siècle notamment aux 15e
et et tout à coup c'est on voit des
châteaux forts ne sont plus fait pour se
défendre ou qui sont faits pour vivre
tout simplement
voilà celui que vous avez derrière vous
qui êtes château de cherveux est en fait
à la lisière est à la limite de sept de
cette espèce de de moyen-âge
conflictuelles et
deux dames horse de la renaissance c'est
tout à la fois un château massif très
évidemment en rapport avec sa fonction
guerrière mais c'est en même temps une
oeuvre architecturale beaucoup plus
raffinée extrêmement intéressante et qui
qui en fait profile la transformation
qui est en train de se confirmer à
l'époque
au fond les châteaux toujours évolué on
s'interroge toujours sur l'authenticité
mais c'est absolument impossible de
retrouver l'authenticité des châteaux
forts il est authentique celui qu'on
voit actuellement
simplement on voit bien qu'il a été
qu'il a évolué au cours des âges alors
celui là il est typiquement en fait
composé donc deux de ses éléments
successives vous avez une base qui est
le châtelet c'est à dire l'entrée d'un
château primitif qui lui a disparu
ne reste plus que l'entrée est au dessus
de ceux châtelet une structure qui
datent de la renaissance qui est
absolument magnifique avec des
colombages qui sont typiquement normand
et surtout 7
ce toit en fait dans karen de bateaux et
et un résultat absolument insolites et
qui est tout à la fois d'un point de vue
esthétique extrêmement puissant
extrêmement remarquable et la question
de l'authenticité évidemment une
question qui au-delà en fait de ces
transformations va toucher la manière
dont le séchage taux vont être en
quelque sorte réhabilité par là par les
différents intervenants au 19e siècle
dans la patrimonialisation la prise en
compte et vous avez en fait une
opposition qui est bien connue des
historiens de l'architecturé entre deux
courants le cours en français qui est
incarnée par les viollet-le-duc et ses
productions où on considère que le
moyen-âge peut aller au-delà de ce que
nous savons de lui c'est à dire qu'il
faut produire quelque chose qui peut
être en quelque sorte à distance de ce
qu'était le produit initial dès lors
qu'il est en phase avec l'image que l'on
se fait du moyen âge ce qui est une
vision qui est très romantique qui est
très proche de 2 de la proposition de
caspar david friedrich le peinte quand
ils disent
on peint ce que l'on voit à l'extérieur
mais il faut également pas ce qui est en
nous voyez il ya cette espèce de
cocktail qui fait que le l'architecte
viollet le duc dans ton voilà par
exemple la réhabilitation des murailles
de carcassonne en fait est un médiateur
il nous inouïe nous réinvente le moyen
âge et en face vous avez les anglais qui
se sont beaucoup plus rigoureux enfin en
tout cas beaucoup plus beaucoup plus
comment dire limités dans leurs dents
les libertés qui s'autorisent incarne
essentiellement par john ruskin qui
partent du principe que la robe
production doit ce fonds doit se faire à
l'identique ce qu'on appelle la
restitution
et si en définitive cette école ce
principe qui va devenir le principe
canonique
nous avons nous sommes régis aujourd'hui
par une charte de venise qui date de
1964 et qui dit en gros dans son article
la reconstruction s'arrête là où
commence l'hypothèse c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui quand on reconstruit on
ne peut le faire qu'en étant certain de
reproduire à l'identique ce qui a existé
dans le passé ce qui est essentiel
frédéric parce que l'essentiel de ce que
vous voulez l'ensemble de ses bâtiments
de nous voyons pour la plupart ont été à
un moment donné ou un autre reconstruit
vous le montrez bien dans votre livre au
fond la plupart de ces châteaux étaient
des ruines qui ont été reconstruites en
particulier à partir du 19ème siècle
selon l'idée comme vous disiez de que
l'on se faisait du du moyen-âge qui est
au fond une sorte de noeux qui est un
peu notre inconscient ce moyen-âge et
ses châteaux symbolise la plupart du
temps l'inconscient de l'europe
en tout cas pour moi bien sûr ces
châteaux vont bien au delà de leur
stricte dimension architecturale voire
même historique
ils sont las le symbole très
certainement de cette espèce de creuser
comme un collectif qui composent qui est
à l'origine de ce qu'est l'europe
aujourd'hui bien sûr et puis à autre
chose une
il ya une dimension littéralement
métaphysique cc château nourrissent
l'imaginaire ils nourrissent la
littérature ils nourrissent le cinéma ce
sont des lieux qui sont totalement
ambivalent paradoxaux le château c'est
un lieu qui est inquiétant mais si tout
a l'air tout à la fois un lieu où l'on
se réfugie c'est un lieu où l'intérieur
était en fête ouvre sur des perspectives
ce que disaient les surréalistes et pour
en revenir pour revenir en arrière vous
avez montré une photo d'un bâtiment qui
est très intéressant qui est le château
de kergonna des ac en bretagne qui est
un exemple absolument étonnant de
conservation de la ruine
voilà c'est celui là en fait le château
qui argue la dgac appartient à un
particulier qui a en quelque sorte
conserver en l'état et qui entretient en
l'état cette ruine au milieu d'une
pelouse parfaitement tendu c'est
quasiment devenu un objet d'art ce
bâtiment quasiment qu'à quasiment des
démonté en fait et le château suivant on
le voit sous deux angles différents
voilà à gauche
on le voit disons sans le village
moderne et et à droite avec le village
moderne
s'il vous plaît nous en dire deux mots
que celui ci alors en fait ces deux
images permettent de distinguer deux
approches photographiques différentes et
et de souligner la dimension encore une
fois symbolique et sts éthique de de cet
univers castrale tel qu'on le perçoit
aujourd'hui vous avez en fait sur la
gauche une vision qui est une vision
disons traditionnel académique élégiaque
et sur la droite une vision qui est
beaucoup plus en rapport avec ce que je
considère être la photo contemporaine ou
tout à coup on contextualise l'objet
dans sa réalité d'aujourd'hui et le le
bâtiment se trouve en tchéquie est ce
que vous voyez au premier plan c'est en
fait un ensemble d'habitations dans deux
dans un contexte urbain contemporain qui
évidemment créé apporte à au château une
dimension quasiment spectrale puisqu'il
semble flotter de manière irréelle sur
ces éléments qui sont tout à fait anodin
tout à fait triviaux et en rapport avec
notre contemporain pourquoi vous avez
une telle passion pour les châteaux
forts avec chopin alors en fait les
châteaux forts je m'intéresse dans une
relation particulière que j'entretiens
avec les bâtiments disons anachronique
et monumentaux j'avais autrefois fait
des photos de bâtiments
lié aux vingt dernières années de
l'architecturé soviétique face de l'urss
et ça m'a semblé être un moyen de
poursuivre un projet personnel cohérent
tout en étant à distance en fait du
projet précédent
c'est à dire une sorte de déclinaison
tout à la fois inattendu et et malgré
tout cohérente avec le lalalala proches
initial auquel avaient donné lieu les
les bâtiments soviétique enfin je suis
très attaché à une définition que donne
larchitecture que donne de
l'architecturé jean nouvel qui donnait
sur un plateau de télévision il ya
quelques temps pour lui
l'architecturé la pétrification d'un
moment de culture c'est exactement de
cette manière là que j'approche
l'article l'architecturé c'est en cela
qu'elle m'intéresse elle pétrifie des
moments de culture et l'intérêt du thème
en fait que nous avons abordé enfin que
que j'ai compilé dans ce livre c'est
précisément de montrer comment les
strates se succèdent les transformations
se succèdent dans un dans un contexte
qui est encore une fois celui de
l'évolution même de l'histoire du dd des
ethnies des groupes humains qui sont
concernés par ces constructions stone
age c'est le nom du livre un gros livre
qui fait plus de 400 pages qui vient de
paraître aux éditions taschen
merci frédéric chaubin ont fait une
pause et on se retrouve juste après avec
marianne régler et thomas leleu
[Musique]
bayonne réglé dans un instant de la vie
de léonard de vinci autre histoire qui
vient de paraître chez gallimard et
l'arpenteur vous reconstituant fait des
instants cruciaux de la vie de grands
artistes c'est votre façon à vous d'en
faire des personnages de romans malin
pression parce que c'est un peu la
grande tendance de ce début de 21e
siècle dans la littérature française
ces deux fictionné la biographie des
gens célèbres c'est un peu ce que vous
faites vous aussi mais c'est sous forme
de nouvelles au fond oui tout à fait
c'est déjà ce que je faisais dans mon
roman précédent vincent qu'on assassine
dans lequel j'aurai passé les deux
dernières années de la vie de vincent
van gogh et c'est vrai que c'est une
grande tendance de la littérature
actuelle on a même donné un nom à ça on
appelle ça l'exo fiction et je lui dirai
en fait que ça correspond à cette
dimension annoncé par margaret atwood
qui dit que à la fin nous devenons tous
des histoires et donc ça consiste à à
s'emparer du potentiel romanesque de la
vie de personnages ayant réellement
existé et de les raconter avec les
instruments de les instruments de la
fiction c'est à dire le point de vue le
dialogue avec ses instruments narratif
pour en faire percevoir tout ou le
potentiel émotionnel
alors je dois commencer par celui là
parce que je le connaissais bien entendu
et pour moi on peut pas vivre pire est
peut-être aussi on ne peut pas on ne
peut rien vivre de mieux c'est
dostoïevski qui quand il avait 28 ans
est fusillé il est fusillé
il est il est en prison il est condamné
à mort
on est sous le règne du tsar nicolas 1er
et un matin on l'emmène au poteau il va
être fusillé l'un sacs de jute sur la
tête c'est quand même un moment
absolument incroyable
dans la vie d'un homme je pense que ça
vous marque au delà touche parce qu'il
n'aurait jamais été l'écrivain qu'il est
devenu écrivain génial s'il n'avait pas
vécu ce moment là c'est certain
c'est certain d'une certaine manière il
traverse la mort et est bon il va quand
même
ensuite être envoyé au bagne enfin ou et
passera je crois deux années mais
évidemment c'est une expérience qui l'a
certainement qu'il a certainement
complètement marqué et qui lui a donné
la possibilité ensuite décrire ses
oeuvres pleines d'humanité qui nous
touche tellement alors dans notre dans
cette petite nouvelle marianne règle et
vous dites qu à un moment enfant on lui
annonce qu'il ne sera pas fusiller on
lui retire son sac de jute de la tête
moi je connaissais l'histoire en disant
qu'il avait été fusillé avec des balles
à blanc
ce qui était encore pire à mon avis vous
êtes sûr de vous savez quelle est la
vraie version à écouter dans les
biographies que j'ai vu on commune on
annonce que la peine est commuée mais
voilà et c'est pas on sait pas
exactement indiqué voilà autre maman
fonda fondateur presque c'est pour le
caravage quand son saint mathieu et
l'ange qui l'avait dont il avait reçu la
commande pour l'église saint louis des
français à rome est refusé c'est sa
première commande officielle était sa
première commande de tableaux
religieuses d'un triptyque trois
tableaux sur sa mathieu et celui là est
refusé et et vous raconter tout ce
moment où il peut pas payer les modèles
voilà c'est celui qui est juste derrière
moi où il commence à se dire qu'il va
falloir qu ils le peignent autrement
pourquoi est-ce que vous avez choisi ce
moment il y en a plein des instants
cruciaux dans la dans la vie de deux du
caravage et une dit plus que mouvementée
pourquoi ce moment là bas tout
simplement je dois dire que le l'idée de
ce tableau qui était qui était un
magnifique tableau qui a été refusé par
ses commanditaires
elle m'a beaucoup intéressé parce qu'en
fait elle fait voir cette situation d'
extrême dépendance dans laquelle
l'artiste se trouve vis-à-vis de ses
commanditaires vis-à-vis de ceux qui ont
le pouvoir de l'argent et est en effet
ce tableau est refusé au caravage alors
même que c'est un c'est un tableau très
original dans sa dans sa composition
très abouti simplement il est refusé
pour deux raisons que je trouve
fascinante à la fois on reproche le fait
que lens soit représentée sous les
traits d'une jeune femme nu dont on
entend on voit vraiment très très bien
toute la nuit dit et grâce à l'art du
gravage et aussi il est refusé parce que
le sang n'est pas du tout représentée
d'une façon grandiose en majesté avec
avec avec la dignité qui pourrait lui
convenir
il est représenté comme un homme normal
et notamment on voit la plante de l'un
de ses pieds qui est sale et ce sont les
raisons pour lesquelles les
commanditaires les héritiers comptarel
il refuse ce tableau au caravage et
et de façon tout à fait légitime le
caravage en est fou de rage c'est
parfaitement compréhensible et le le
tableau qu'il peindra à la place de
celui ci pour s'efforcer de complaire à
ses commanditaires sera beaucoup plus
académique et c'est celui qu'on voit
aujourd'hui à l'heure actuelle dans
l'église saint louis des français
mais ce moment m'a passionné parce que
c'est celui où dans le fond l'artiste
doit mobiliser en lui même une énergie
gigantesque à la fois pour surmonter
cette blessure narcissique qui est le
refus de son travail et aussi pour
trouver l'énergie de proposer autre
chose
autre chose qui va qui va plaire qui va
lui donner la possibilité d'être payés
et qui va lui donner la possibilité de
poursuivre son travail son travail
artistique d'être reconnu dans son nid
dans son effort alors pourquoi des
instants dans la vie de les instants
dans la vie de caravage de même que des
instants dans la vie de l'art de vinci
on pourrait en écrire une dizaine une
quinzaine une vingtaine voilà j'ai
choisi celui-là mais bien évidemment sur
epte on se dire d'autre dans la vie de
théophile gautier il ya vous avez choisi
ce moment alors théophile gautier c'est
l'auteur du capitaine fracasse tout cas
c'est son oeuvre qui a traversé les
siècles mais il a écrit aussi giselle un
ballet l'instant que vous racontez ça se
passe lors de la première en 1841 au
moment où il
il est amoureux de de cette danseuse
carlotta grisy pour qui il a il a écrit
ce ballet alors pourquoi ce moment là
alors moi j'ai été absolument fasciné en
découvrant dans la dans la vie de
théophile gautier qu'en fait ils avaient
été et père du mans amoureux de de
karlovac grésy et et est en fait il
il s'est mis en ménage il a vécu avec la
soeur de celle ci est d'une certaine
manière c'est ce ce décalage entre le
les sentiments de l'écrivain son effort
pour être aimé et il est allé jusqu'à
écrire ce merveilleux livret de gisèle
dans un os dans l'espoir d'obtenir le
l'amour de 2,7 cette merveilleuse
ballerine est en réalité il s'est
retrouvé à vivre et avoir des enfants
avec sa soeur et jusqu'à la fin de sa
vie il ne cesse de supplier carlo cas de
répondre à son amour de lui accorder les
rendez-vous et de lui appartenir et
c'est ce décalage dribble tragique qui
me semble d'ailleurs inscrit au coeur
même du livret de gisèle puisque gisèle
raconte l'histoire de d'une femme qui
meurt parce que l'homme qu'elle aime la
trahit son amour et c'est comme si tu
enfiles gauthier avait sans le savoir
presque raconter sa propre histoire
d'amour dans giselle l'histoire d'amour
il sur damour malheureux qu'il
s'apprêtait à vivre et qu'ils allaient
être l'histoire de sa vie voilà c'est ce
ce décalage entre le désir d'être aimé
et la réalité qui m'a qui m'a absolument
fasciné dans le dans l'histoire de
dieulefit côtier il ya beaucoup de
l'histoire dans ce livre on peut pas
tout les raconter yade jk rowling
l'auteur d'harry potter alors là j'ai
l'instant crucial
effectivement dans son cas elle c'est le
moment où elle a un imaginer harry
potter tout le monde se demande à quel
moment elle a eu cette extraordinaire et
des qui va la rendre multimilliardaire
vous vous lavez raconté dans un bus dans
un train dans un train et ce n'est pas
quelque chose que j'ai inventé c'est à
dire c'est elle a admis que enfin elle a
raconté que c'était dans un train
qu'elle avait eu cette idée là c'était
vraiment dans un train manchester
londres qu'elle avait eu cette idée et
elle a raconté dans une interview que
voilà le monde de harry potter lui était
apparu à ce moment là dans un train et
j'ai voulu raconter cette histoire parce
que je suis une enfant fasciné par les
gens qui comme du curling sont des
créateurs de monde ça à voir bien sûr
avec avec ma propre façon de décrire
c'est à dire que pour ma part c'est la
documentation qui m'inspire moi je
travaille à partir de à partir
d'éléments biographiques dément
historiques avérés et et elle n'a été
capable de d'imaginer tout cet univers
de des sortilèges de l'école de
sorcellerie de poudlard et c'est
véritablement un hommage à ce pouvoir
créateur qu'elle a que j'ai voulu lui
rendre le livre s'intitule un instant
dans la ville les nerfs de vinci et
autres histoires il vient de paraître
chez gallimard et l'arpenteur il est
signé marianne réglé
[Musique]
thomas leleu vous êtes l'homme qui a
imposé sur les scènes du monde entier le
tuba en tant qu'instrument roi
aujourd'hui vous sortez un nouvel album
intitulé born to move heures sachant que
le groove c'est le rythme et c'est ce
qui fait bouger cplc culte est qu un
tubiste est intitulé son dernier album
ainsi un roi de la funk ou de la soul
encore on aurait compris
mais un tubiste il fallait le faire
ouais en fait j'avais jésus toujours eu
envie de proposer quelque chose d'un peu
d'un peu différent qui sortait un petit
peu de la musique classique qui reste
mon éducation et ma formation j'ai
toujours été attiré par ces musiques
rythmées de qq petit et je trouve qu'en
fait ça fonctionne plutôt pas mal dans
cet album qui est multi styles puisqu'on
passe de l'être ou swing bossa nova
musique africaine et a beaucoup beaucoup
de choses thomas leleu avant qu'on
s'intéresse plus particulièrement à cet
album je vous avez reçue en 2019 au
moment où vous avez sorti le précédent
entre temps il ya eu on a traversé le
vide
le confinement au strip j'imagine que
vous n'avez pas dû faire beaucoup de
concerts depuis depuis un peu plus d'un
an maintenant
mais surtout vous avez dû rester confiné
comment on fait pour jouer du tuba quand
on est confiné
est-ce qu'on peut jouer du tout buzz
chez soi vous mâcher s'en alarme
j'ai la chance de ne pas être un
problème avec mes voisins je leur
demande régulièrement si ça les dérange
pas et puis je reste assez raisonnable
sur les horaires donc ça va pour
l'instant ça va vous avez souffert de ne
pas pouvoir jouer en public
oui bien sûr fait c'est difficile d'être
privé de concert après il ya eu cette
petite fenêtre à l'été dernier où j'ai
refait quelques concerts mais quelque
part cette opportunité d'avoir du temps
je les fais 10 pour préparer justement
cet album pour préparer la flore qui
essayait de faire les choses de prendre
le temps de faire les choses
bon il faut savoir que vous quand vous
faites des concerts me fait vraiment des
concerts dans le monde entier fait
énormément de concerts en asie en chine
en particulier aux états unis vous a été
le premier à faire une tournée où vous
étiez seul sur scène à jouer du tuba
aussi assez gonflé ça a été un vrai
succès donc quand on parle de conserve
ou c'est vraiment dans le monde entier
quand est ce que vous pouvez espérer
reprendre tous à ce rythme normal
j'espère le plus vite possible et je
crois ce qu'ils nient ce qui me
permettra de retourner à l'étranger en
tout cas en dehors de l'europe
ce sera à vous faire vacciner pour
éviter tout ce qui est quarantaine et
cetera mais là on propose déjà des dates
hors navy pour novembre prochain
donc j'espère pouvoir les honorer alors
regardons tout de suite un extrait du
clip de dans des morceaux de born to
move c'est ce que vous l'avez intitulé
schubertiade on regarde le clip
[Musique]
je
parent
[Musique]
à
quand on voit ce clip en tout cas ceux
qui ne vous connaissent pas encore
thomas leleu on comprend mieux comment
vous avez fait de cet instrument qui est
considéré comme le le pech idernes des
instruments parce qu'il a un son très
très grave qu'il est gros on le tient
dans ses bras comme ça si très
particulier normalement il est ce un
instrument de fanfares un instrument
qu'on met au fond de l'orchestré vous
voulez me devant et et vous avez eu
beaucoup de succès en réussissant cette
prouesse mais on comprend pourquoi pas
ce kung fu avec vous vous arrivez à le
faire chanter
cet instrument y vous jouez moins graves
que les autres
ouais c'est vrai et en fait c'est il est
aussi question de plans musicaux de
plans sonores
parce que pour pouvoir passer au dessus
de mes musiciens c'est à dire qu'on
entende vraiment clairement le tubage
suis obligé de jouer dans la tessiture
médium aigu et non pas dans le grave
comme comme je le faisais quand j'étais
alors alors qu'être et du coup j'essaie
de donner cette image un peu plus un peu
plus pop abondent dans ce nouvel album
est une image aussi un peu plus j'irai
en tout plus sexy ouais je connais par
le tube a fait quand même oui la fanfare
souvent de faire ce que ce qu'on appelle
des crossover pour les musiciens
classiques c'est tout un coup de jouer
des musiques de films jouer des chansons
brésiliennes ou des ou des chansons
populaires de prendre de la muse de
faire de la musique populaire au fond
les crossover c'est c'est très souvent
c'est comme ça qu'on consomme peu le
public qui n'aime pas forcément le
classique mais vous vous êtes un peu
obligé au fond parce que le répertoire
du tuba il est quand même extrêmement
limité le crossover
c'était naturel pour vous à la fois ça
vient forcément de l'instrument le fait
qu'il n'y ait pas vraiment de tradition
avec avec le tube adam parr répertoire
solis original j'entends un répertoire
très large et c'est surtout un goût
personnel pour ce pour ce genre de
musique j'ai toujours aimé les musiques
du monde des musiques dansantes le
groove c'est ça qui m'a donné envie de
monter sur scène de faire de la musique
et ça permet du coup de faire connaître
le tuba d'internet façon mais aussi de
de choper pour reprendre vos mots un
public un peu plus large et celui de la
musique classique
si vous aimiez tant les musées
du monde et les musiques actuelles
pourquoi vous n'avez pas joué d'un autre
instrument que le tuba or il aurait
simplifié la vie quand même s'il avait
su
mais non je crois que j'étais aussi
attirés par par l'orchestré parler son
grave s'était pas au départ je sais pas
vraiment ce que je voulais c'est ce que
je voulais faire au départ j'ai commencé
le cube à un peu comme comme un comme un
petit garçon qui vont au conservatoire
qui fait de la musique sans forcément
avoir une perspective de devenir
musicien professionnel et puis après sur
mon chemin j'ai rencontré des musiciens
j'ai connu des musiques les découverts
de minutes
on sait ce qui m'a donné envie de
denfert mon métier et les partager avec
avec le plus grand nombre au fond d'eux
les deux seuls tubiste que je connais
c'est vous et benjamin biolay qui lui
aussi enfin conservées au conservatoire
il a pris le tuba et ni l'un ni l'autre
deux jouent tellement classique au fond
vous êtes tous les deux d'aller vers des
univers très différents
on vous avez vous a écouté on va vous
écoutez interpréter marie gobeil il ya
pas deux il n'y a pas de clip pour fins
pas encore de clip pour celui là on va
l'écouter avec le petit système à genoux
marigot belle
[Musique]
est ce que vous êtes parvenu à déjà
faire danser des gens dans le tuba je
crois que oui et je crois que oui et cet
album il est il était c'est aussi pour
ça et les retours que j'ai alors
évidemment je n'ai pas encore joué en
public donc ça reste très virtuel
finalement ce sont les messages que je
reçois ci via les réseaux sociaux ou les
certains programmateurs de concerts mais
disent mais ça ça donne la pêche ça nous
donne envie de danser envie de bouger
et donc c'est plutôt positif parce que
c'était vraiment l'objectif alors
faisons ces disques mais sur scène
normalement thomas leleu vous jouez à 6
est ce que à la suite de ce disque que
vous allez vous mettre à jouer debout
ouais je pense que je vais être obligé
parce que y'a quand on est assis à ses
côtés statique et c'est vraiment musique
classique alors que là on est vraiment
dans un monde enfin il faut imaginer une
communion avec un public et essayer
d'aller les chercher les faire danser et
je pense même que les concerts que je
ferais il y aura sans doute une partie
de la jauge qui fera qu'il sera debout
pourquoi jouez vous aussi dans
l'allemand c'est parce que l'instrument
est lourd parce qu'il est encombrant
parce que comme je disais il faut on le
tient dans ses bras
ouais parce que l'instrument pèse 10 kg
alors bon pour la musique classique on a
quand même besoin justement d'une
certaine concentration et d'être sûres
sont sur son axe qui sont à la
respiration etc
toutes les techniques cet apprentissage
qu'on a qu'on découvre et de points
qu'on apprend tout au long de nos études
alors que je pense que pour ce genre de
musique c'est plus se voit la ccc plus
impétueux comment dire c'est ça marche
mieux de le faire de le faire de bout
voilà et de pouvoir bouger de pouvoir
danser en même temps à jouer ce genre de
musique en étant assis et statique ça
marche pas cet album born to move il ya
un certain nombre de musiciens dans le
précédent vous étiez en trio je faisais
allusion tout à l'heure la tournée que
vous avez fait aux états unis où vous
étiez vraiment seul je crois vous étiez
vraiment seul sur scène comment comment
ça se passe quand on est seul sur scène
avec un tuba
quel spectacle offre ton à la salle
j'étais pas j'étais pas seul j'étais
accompagné par un piano mais c'est vrai
que du coup c'est une formation quand
même très réduite et il faut essayer de
trouver justement un répertoire un peu
crossover forcément parce que c'est vrai
que si je joue que des pièces originales
pour pour tuba et piano très franchement
je pense que le public s'en va au bout
de dix minutes
donc il faut trouver quand même vu des
pièces de pièces de genre de dire
d'opéra des musiques de films voilà
tomber un petit peu j'irai dans la
facilité mais avec ben tout ce que je
voulais aussi c'était faire découvrir ma
propre musique m'est propre sonorité est
passé de ce rôle d'interprète qu'on ait
finalement quand on est musicien
classique au rôle de créateur de
compositeurs même puisqu'un certain
nombre de morceaux que vous allez vous
avez composer vous même je le disais
c'est vous qui avez fait du tuba un
instrument l'instrument roi je disais je
disais mais au fond un instrument de
soliste réellement avec des petites
formations ça devient c'est vous la star
quoi il sait le tuba qui est là qu est
la vedette
est-ce que vous parvenez encore à jouer
avec un orchestre est ce qu'est ce que
est ce que vous pouvez vous retrouver
avec beaucoup de musiciens ou es ce que
vous avez pris toutes les mauvaises
habitudes du soliste maintenant je crois
que mon jeu s'est adapté de soliste
maintenant enfin voilà chez je sais que
puis j'ai aussi c'est ce caractère c'est
à dire que quand je suis au fond de
l'eau requête aux fins d'une formation
de 80 musiciens non je m'ennuie je
m'ennuie un petit peu en fait c'est pas
vraiment le même métier mais c'est vrai
que je préfère en tout cas en ce moment
dans cette période de ma vie je
préférais tueur devant de la scène et
faire découvrir un projet artistique
plutôt que d'être finalement réduit à
une touche de piano
c'est ce qu'on est quand on est une
ville dont 20 dans un orchestre et le
tuba c'est ça apporte juste une couleur
quand vous aviez 19 ans quand vous êtes
retrouvés dans leur castres vous étiez
assez jeune avec votre votre tube à vous
aviez déjà l'idée à ce moment-là de vous
retrouver devant la scène est ici oui on
n'a pas essayé de vous dissuader en vous
disant mon vieux avec un tuba tu n'as
aucune chance
alors j'en ai rêvé depuis mon
adolescence même bien avant de rentrer à
l'opéra de marseille est bien sûr que
quand je parlais de mon projet de faire
des concerts en soliste avec mon tuba
tout le monde me disait mais thomas tu
rêves ça n'est pas possible tu n'y
arriveras jamais et heureusement que je
n'ai jamais écouté ces gens là parce
qu'aujourd'hui ça à midi dans 15 ans
peut-être mais aujourd'hui c'est mon
activité je ne sais plus que ça et je
suis super épanouie à passer comme ça de
la musique classique au crossover aux
musiques du monde ocha c'est quelque
chose que j'adore et j'ai bien fait pas
écouter ces gens là vous vous entourez
aujourd'hui de d'arrangeur j'imagine
parce que les morceaux que vous jouez
vous interprétez au tuba vous êtes le
premier à les jouer au tuba il a fallu
il faut il faut une grande transcription
j'imagine adaptée à cet instrument est
ce que vous avez eu des échecs
qu'est-ce qu'il ya des morceaux vous
êtes dit tiens celui là je rêverais de
jouer puis vraiment c'est impossible à
jouer le tuba alors je me suis toujours
fixé pour objectif
j'avais cette phrase rien est impossible
je suis capable de tout faire de tout
jouer voilà donc on peut on dit je dois
m'adapter ja trouver des solutions et
quand on a travaillé sur born to rouvre
on a mac et et voilà on a essayé plein
de choses en studio sur ordinateur sans
forcément les instruments live des trois
instrumentistes et il y avait des
certains certaine esthétique qui ne
fonctionnait pas donc on est on est
parti par exemple est une ballade qui
s'appelle room with you a été écrite en
binaire et on a réarrangé saint laurent
elle me bat mon arrangeur là m'a proposé
de la rangée en ternaire en vals un
petit peu l'anti jazz et ça fonctionne
très bien et en fait quand on est partis
du binaire c'était pas du tout pas du
tout satisfaisant donc vous continuez
vous persistez vous pensez que rien est
impossible au tuba rien ne régissait
rien est impossible
rien ne résistera pas j'imagine que vous
avez essayé le hard rock
vous avez essayé le reggae
vous avez essayé le funk la techno tout
tout est possible ouais moi j'aime bien
j'aime bien cette idée justement de
passer d'un monde à l'autre d'une
musique à l'autre et en fait ça reste de
la musique d'éviter vous savez en masse
côté la france ou dans le monde de la
musique notamment de mettre les gens
vraiment dans des cafés on est musicien
classique jazz rock et les ponts on voit
entre entre tous ces styles sont
complètement c'est un petit peu
difficile parfois et moi je me suis j'ai
essayé de me fixer aucune limite est de
passer d'un style à l'autre et du moment
en effet de le faire du mieux qu'on peut
avec toute mon équipe et je pense que
sur cet album ça marche plutôt bien
j'espère en tout cas
born to move c'est le titre de cet album
mais si thomas leleu et puis bon retour
sur scène dès que ce sera possible je
vous remercie tous les trois d'avoir
participé à cette émission
je vous remercie aussi nous avoir suivis
et je vous donne rendez-vous au prochain
numéro
[Musique]